yeah [ __ ] hi guys okay so this is gonna
be a strobe light vlog because I don't
know why my camera is doing this on my
computer but it is and I can't figure
out how to make it stop doing it
I brought lights closer I just don't
know
Oh first class problems my god hi guys
um so I'm in LA right now and I know
that you thought oh if she's in Elliot
there's not gonna be a male vlog wrong
you thought wrong things you thought the
wrong things because I grab my mail with
me out to LA and I haven't opened any of
it yet I'm gonna open it right now so
let's do it
also I'm talking a little bit quieter
because um I'm in a hotel and the walls
seem like they're a little bit thin so
my self-consciousness is taking over so
is my acid trip Venus look at these legs
I'm sorry this is substract me alright
I'm gonna try and get through this
quickly because these lights are
annoying hey if anyone knows why it's
doing this please tell me because it
didn't ever do this before
PMS my computer's PMS a what a [ __ ]
alright come here to me male get into my
hands like good male does
okay and we're back let's do this
okay first here's some letters this is
from pair of Ian Ayre ooh what a fun
name you have that's not your name Oh
Sam Burnett from your sealant oh my
goodness
new zealand house Frodo
do you see The Hobbit often you live
near them are they bad neighbors they
party too loud seems like they probably
do do grace what's up [ __ ] my name is
Sam I'm a guy FYI how's my pin and chip
very nice for a man very nice um thought
I'd drop you a note to say hi your vids
make my day usually upload them about
5:00 p.m. New Zealand time which is
about when I arrived home from
University each day oh you're welcome
I knew that and that's why I did that
sake some really um oh you're gonna come
to the people's Improv Theater that's
awesome please whenever you're in the
States as they say and come to the
people's Improv Theater
let's see some improv stay classy Sam ah
say hi to Mae Murray Michelle and your
mom for me
you're my mum my mum I will say hello to
my mom for me I think so I think serious
letter is it visually appealing oh
please oh please this is so great thank
you Sam it's so nice oh boy from New
Zealand just wrote a letter to a girl in
New York that's in LA right now what a
world is this okay ooh postcards
postcards
okay Morocco who's this friend
Zoe this is from Zoe again so I keep
sending me all these awesome postcards
and this is a Moroccan postcard Thank
You Joey I hope you're doing really
really well out in Chicago I hope your
improv us going possibly um let's see
this postcard is Oh Oh No Australia who
know this is funny that they post of us
covered that up post office hates
Australia oh okay this is from Daniel
Daniel you have really amazing pemon
ship - oh my god grace just wanted to
say hey thank you for making weekdays
slightly more bearable my friends and I
enjoy screwing around in our school
lessons quote in all of your hilarious
antics Oh anything I can do to make your
teachers life more of a living hell I'm
gonna try thank you so much for sending
this we don't sell funfetti in Australia
and that makes me sad oh no you know
what you can do I've been thinking about
this a lot people have sent me messages
about this that you can take Jimmy's or
sprinkles whatever you call them I call
them Jimmy's because I'm from South
Jersey and those will know I call them
not and I'm gonna get that regular
vanilla cake batter and sprinkle them in
there
that's essentially what funfetti cake is
but America made it looked like it was
another product that we needed to have
in our lives and that's why they made
funfetti because we love consumerism
we just wanna lose this from Kaylie
Giddings Oh your name son [ __ ] it your
name sounds like um like it should be
one of the like a titmouse
Westlake Village California I'm in your
state and your stamp is really cool it
to cat and that cat looks like a total
[ __ ] so I like it
Oh open em what the crap is this what is
the 50 weirdness already wow this is
amazing this is all of my life like a
cat nub sq
never knowing you know that song okay
Wow your ham and chip your hand Manship
is so cute and tiny huggers in events if
my writing goes all crooked there are no
damn lines I know it's crazy
look at all this stuff that she put
these are 3d stickers so they pop up and
they it's like um Braille or stickers so
cool okay Lee this is such a nice letter
so I'm reading it all in my head I
shouldn't do that a video Thank You
Kaylee for this letter that's so so nice
of you that's so cool really because my
air conditioning just went off my candy
your everything that's happening in the
hall which means it they can hear
everything that's happening here
Jaden's okay more news Oh another
postcard New York Cuban haze it's New
York and the Statue of Liberty is saying
you've been hazed because just I stand
big okay who's this fan Oh Chris
Christian Brill and what a nice little
name it gives it's like a your last name
sounds like an exclamation point well
hmm I'm from eventless longhorn
Pennsylvania Oh give yourself some
credit
oh you're originally from Germany that's
interesting
born and raised there found this
postcard while in New York I've always
liked New York but since I know you are
of your existence it's even awesomer why
that's cool excuse me please let me know
your favorite colors I want to make a
scarf wow that is so nice to be honest
um that's really really too much that's
so nice of you
colors I like all colors I don't really
have a favorite color and if you send me
a scarf I'm gonna pass out because
that's really really very very sweet and
I want to learn how to knit but I know I
won't learn on account of I am lazy on
learning new things but at least some
self-aware about it huh
one Estella from Illinois oh don't show
your address Wow and I want to know
what's in this letter this is a great
blanket oh man that's awesome nyan cat
every time I try to do the nyan cat song
he turns into the HAP circumstance song
so do you know these dogs out uggg go
that's not nyan cat clearly oh my god
grace you don't understand how much I
love your videos and rarity I don't but
thank you so much that's so nice of you
my sister never literally watch your
videos right when they come out and
almost died after don't die stop
integrates all looks so nice I don't
know the firmer but you reblogged a
video I post on tumblr of me playing
Dance Dance Revolution here commentator
and did I remember that that was really
really cool thank you so much for making
the video that was awesome of you and
hilarious because I don't know how you
do that with technology like that so
thank you thank you so much from JP one
Thank You Lauren from Illinois doesn't
sound like it should be from Illinois
that's me being stereotyped Oh who's
this fun Melanie Landy from Hollister
California is that where they started
the khlo
that would make sense do you wear
Hollister or are you like so over it
because you grew up in how store your
whole life right I get you whoa this is
an awesome owner grace just saying thank
you for making me laugh and smile every
day sincerely Melanie Landy what a cool
letter right to the point
Thank You Melanie this is awesome so
cool and you have do you go to Catholic
school because you're a beautiful
cursive and I feel like don't people if
you have a cursive or people that have
nuns that force them to have beautiful
cursive oh no did I get no I didn't get
this one yet I'll do this one first Oh
Liberty Bell Sunday it's in history all
wrapped into one Elizabeth
DiMaggio from Yorktown Heights New York
I didn't really want to lick the
envelope sorry
tape is unattractive I tape all my ups
after I like them because I don't press
my saliva to get the job done just me
absolutely love your videos but do you
know what I love even more your real
laugh it's so the cutest eggs here's a
bracelet I made for you I hope you like
it and it will actually wear it this is
an awesome bracelet look at this how did
you make this how did you make this I'll
put it on right now oh my goodness this
is such a cool thing when I was in high
school middle school I used to UM try
and make all my own bracelets too out of
hemp
you know him hmm and I was always really
bad at it
me never turned out that well and I
would always end up just a tying like a
seashell onto it and it was really
cheesy and then I'd wear it once oh it's
pretty thank you so much this is so
pretty
thank you I love it
Elizabeth DiMaggio thank you that's so
nice
are you guys having cataracts yet from
the flashing lights sorry excuse me
double sorry okay what's this Gracie
school smell me no I will anyway doesn't
smell like anything
did you just Punk me i manatee Oh a
manatee oh my god be my friend oh look
at little manatee I'll be that manner to
spend or you asked me to be your friend
um sure what are your biggest fears oh
right see we're so close now you should
know that you can never come back oh
fish I eat fish delicious protein what
the crap whoa dude grace you are [ __ ]
cool I love you me and my friend have a
youtube channel called the yummy lumps
whoa yummy lumps that's cool that sounds
pretty interesting right it sounds like
you guys like each other's boobs but
that's just me
you should make yummy lumps on Thursday
and teach everybody a thing or two
oh and you made art look at the art so
cool maybe I will try and make some
yummy lumps
who knows maybe I will try it out this
thank you for the letter by the way
those so nice of you to send that Thank
You Keith Claire arms shop grace please
do not show my address okay I won't a
success so far didn't show it but I said
your name I'll hook us okay whoops
grace read this first okay you have so
many directions going on here wow this
is another letter that opens what grace
it's a pun because of the food on the
card is called Rach I ruined it by oh I
I've ruined the bites but
could rock what you rock you lack food
that this is something since you rock
but I'm so confused what because the
food on the card is called rock oh this
food is called rock that's what it's
called I've never seen this food before
this to me looks like I don't know
tie-dyed tofu or something no whoa grace
how are you this is me waiting on a
reply I'm good
good I thought I'd send you a letter now
that you've got a paper box
Oh oh thank you oh reading it in my head
again on a video sorry guys um this is
really sweet
wait what did you do you made a card of
Scottish words for me and their
explanations here's a list of some
common words that are used in Scotland
whoa Baron BAE Bayern Bayern is a child
you guys are crazy in Scotland Blitzer
is chatter with someone ha ha
well I've been blithering too much on
this video this is awesome whoa and then
you send me a postcard of Prince Street
in Edinboro that's a beautiful place
look at all that beauty we thank you so
so much Claire this is so nice I'll read
the rest of this after I turn the video
off I found nothing it's like whoa okay
let's open these Robert rune thank you
for sending this envelope Robert okay
Open Sesame
dear grace I'm a big fan I think you're
funny beautiful amazing I think you are
all of those things and more here's a
picture made of you riding a unicorn in
the Arizona desert where I live have a
great day all the best Robert
this is pretty fantastic thank you so
much Robert you have an art career in
your future and I'm not joking this is
fantastic
and you did capture my true fear of
being on top of a unicorn in the desert
I do look a little scared but excited
really excited thank you so much that
was so sweet of you oh okay and this
last one is from Jeanette be something
the thing is covering her name please do
not bend okay I will not Bend this oh my
gosh
what is it are you from Orlando Florida
yes get out of there yay oh cool you
made this graphic of my name and all the
days of the week and then there's
stickers same Mickey called it I called
it a thing called it I think I'm psychic
like okay hey Gracie I'm Jeanette but
everyone called me Jojo I'm 22 and I
live in Orlando Florida I hate long
walks on the beach and I love oh wait
wrong person ah jokes
she's good jokes I'm Jojo Braun oh cool
have a magical day you really are from
Maryland oh you told me I'm a magical
day that's what Mickey would have said
oh my gosh thank you so much this is so
awesome thank you for making this
beautiful you guys are all so artistic
I did alright guys thank you so much for
sending email that's so cool of you um
and I'm gonna be in LA until next
weekend so there's that I hope you guys
have a good everything helped you have a
kid everything bye yeah sorry there's a
little more than I forgot it was burden
everything all my food from Scott
Swanson are you related to Ron Swanson
are you related to a fictional character
give to me this this is awesome
office impressions well here's an
impression for you hmm
George corner mm-hmm how's my pressure
first buddy thank you so much as this so
sweet it came with the letter O let's
how to here are some useful mail openers
to help you on your mail date please be
careful
they race us in them below are some do's
and don'ts this is awesome thank you
thank you so so much
that's so wonderful Scott Swanson your
awesome man thank you so much and thank
you again everyone that's definitely
okay bye
and